este vídeo ha sido posible gracias a
manes que más en un momento
[Aplausos]
[Música]
terremoto político queridos amigos
amigas así es como podemos describir el
enorme vuelco político que se ha
producido en colombia un país enfrentado
a una de las elecciones más importantes
de toda su historia y es que veréis
antes de la primera vuelta todas las
encuestas señalaban que por primera vez
un proyecto claramente de izquierdas muy
de izquierdas podía convertirse la
opción favorita de los colombianos y
sabéis que eso es exactamente lo que
pasó
[Música]
el centroderecha y en general la clase
política tradicional del país fueron
borrados del mapa el ex alcalde de
medellín federico gutiérrez fico el
candidato de centroderecha que aglutinó
los apoyos de fuerzas como el partido de
la u el partido conservador el partido
liberal cambio radical o el centro
democrático ni siquiera pasó a segunda
vuelta contar con el respaldo de pesos
pesados de la política colombiana de la
talla de césar gaviria andrés pastrana o
incluso el mismísimo álvaro uribe por no
hablar del propio presidente iván duque
no le valió absolutamente de nada los
colombianos dijeron basta a los
políticos de siempre
[Música]
de esta forma a gustavo petro el azote
de la derecha y uno de los iconos de la
actual izquierda latinoamericana ganó la
primera vuelta claro que quizás lo hizo
de una forma muy pero que muy diferente
a lo que se esperaba que rodolfo
hernández un candidato independiente le
viera al zarpazo a federico gutiérrez y
ccoo es algo que puede convertirse en su
peor pesadilla
este es realmente el escenario más
difícil imaginable para petro y no creo
que su equipo de campaña esté muy
contento será una lucha cuesta arriba
para él en la segunda ronda sandra
botero analista política de la
universidad de rosario en bogotá ahora
petro se han complicado y mucho las
matemáticas rodolfo hernández acapara
buena parte del voto anti establishment
que el mismo petro persigue y no sólo
eso en conjunto los candidatos que no
pasaron a segunda vuelta sumaron más de
6 millones de votos pues bien ahora la
mayoría apoyan a rodolfo hernández
contra petro para colmo este candidato
de izquierdas ya no pueden arbolar el
discurso del cambio porque si el
auténtico outsider de la política
colombiana ya no es él sino su
contrincante ahora bien que explica
semejante vuelco electoral en colombia
porque el centroderecha y el uribismo
han recibido semejante castigo y quizás
la pregunta más importante de todas qué
va a pasar con colombia
pero antes llega un momento en la vida
de un hombre en el que se tiene que
afeitar ahí abajo y creedme se os digo
que no os recomiendo que utilicéis una
maquinilla normal hace lo que queráis
pero un amigo mío lo intento y desde
entonces la llamamos el castrato no os
digo más dicho de otra forma que sólo
hay una opción realista para poderse
depilar y esa opción es mans que en el
paquete de mans cake que podéis ver aquí
se incluye esta maravilla que es en la
un mover o sea el cortacésped cosa
tecnología única skin safe evita que nos
cortemos tranquilos no os voy a hacer
una demostración del arte de la cámara
por supuesto que la podemos usar bajo la
ducha bajo el agua ningún problema man
scape se puede mojar además que esta
maquinilla tiene una lucecita de led que
nos ayuda a ver mejor en las partes más
oscuras de nuestro cuerpo y tiene hasta
un travel log para cuando nos vamos de
viaje pero no sólo eso además de esta
maquinilla el paquete de manos que
incluye esta depiladora para los pelos
de la nariz la llamada with cracker o
rompe hierbas aquí la podéis ver que
funciona a las mil maravillas y además
también incluye dos desodorantes
diseñados especialmente para el /
masculina el crop preservar y el crop
river ahora que llega el verano os
vendrán especialmente bien y como
siempre tenemos un descuento muy
especial para todos vosotros que seguís
visual político básicamente si utilizáis
el código vps conseguiréis un 20% de
descuento más el envío internacional
gratuito vamos estéis donde estéis
podría recibir más skate más un boxer y
un neceser de regalo recordad amigos más
que las herramientas perfectas para
proteger vuestras partes más preciadas y
ahora sí vamos a ver un poco de historia
[Música]
el fin de una era
durante las últimas décadas colombia ha
sido una especie de rara avis en la
política latinoamericana digamos que
hablamos de un país que habitualmente ha
ido por libre y que ha sido inmune a las
modas de la región
[Música]
por ejemplo mientras que durante los
años 60 y 70 latinoamerica se llenaba de
dictaduras militares de derecha colombia
se mantuvo como una democracia tan
estable como restringida en la que dos
partidos el liberal y el conservador se
alternaban el poder luego durante
finales de los 90 y comienzos de la
década de los 2000 al tiempo que la
región comenzó a girar hacia la
izquierda dando lugar a lo que se
conoció como el socialismo del siglo 21
la política colombiana empezó a
inclinarse hacia el lado contrario hasta
el punto de terminar en el año 2002
dándole el poder a álvaro uribe un
candidato fuerte del centroderecha que
de una forma u otra ha dominado la
política colombiana hasta hoy mientras
que en el resto de américa latina- se
han producido alternancias muy abruptas
colombia fue otra vez la excepción
[Música]
y lo cierto es que aparentemente las
cosas han ido relativamente bien
[Música]
en términos reales tal y como podéis ver
entre 1999 y 2019 el pib per cápita
colombiano creció un ritmo del 2,4 por
ciento anual no es para tirar cohetes
pero por ejemplo para que os hagáis una
idea supone el doble de lo que creció
eeuu durante el mismo período de tiempo
2,5 veces más que el crecimiento de
españa y brass 4 veces el crecimiento de
países como méjico o la argentina
colombia prácticamente igualó el
desempeño de chile durante las últimas
dos décadas y por supuesto esto vino
acompañado de importantes cambios
sociales la violencia se desplomó el
número de jóvenes cursando estudios
terciarios se cuadriplicó y
prácticamente todos los indicadores
sociales mejoraron con mucha fuerza
incluso ahora la recuperación del
coronavirus ha sido una de las más
rápidas de toda américa latina en 2021
la economía ya había sobrepasado su
nivel prepa tenia y por ejemplo la
producción industrial pues pandemia era
un 7 por ciento superior a la del 2019
y no se trata solo de la economía a
nivel exterior colombia también ha
cobrado peso sin ir más lejos el país ha
incorporado a la ocde hace 5 años se
convirtió en el primer país de américa
latina en obtener el estatus de socio
global de la otan y recientemente en
abril de 2022 el presidente joe biden
designó a colombia como aliado principal
fuera de la otan hubo un estatus que
conlleva un trato preferente en materia
de seguridad y defensa pero amigos
amigas hasta ahora las últimas
elecciones han sido un golpe de la mesa
un punto de inflexión quien lo ha
cambiado todo digamos que colombia ha
dicho basta a los partidos tradicionales
al centroderecha al uribismo y a todo lo
que tenga que ver con ellos y la
pregunta que podemos hacer no sé es
porque qué demonios ha provocado este
enorme cambio si los datos aparentemente
no son nada malos pues bien la respuesta
sin ir más lejos la podemos encontrar en
lo que ha sido la presidencia de iván
duque atentos
[Música]
[Aplausos]
un presidente maldito
y bando que se presentó a las elecciones
con grandes promesas de cambio
transformación y modernización de la
economía y la sociedad colombiana sin
embargo lo cierto es que casi podríamos
decir que su mandato ha estado maldito
durante estos cuatro años colombia ha
sufrido una pandemia o un huracán de
fuerza 5 las mayores revueltas sociales
en 70 años una crisis migratoria sin
precedentes y hasta una crisis
internacional de la energía y los
productos alimentarios más difícil
imposible evidentemente de escapar de
todo esto era una misión muy pero que
muy complicada así que el nivel de
aprobación del presidente duque ha
llegado a las elecciones con un
paupérrimo 28 por ciento ni más ni menos
que el 85 por ciento de los colombianos
consideran que el país está en la
dirección equivocada claro que el
presidente tampoco empezó con buen pie
por él y porque la oposición no le dio
tregua en 2019 por ejemplo las
manifestaciones y las protestas
inundaron las calles del país para
denunciar las supuestas intenciones del
presidente de privatizar empresas
públicas reducir el salario mínimo para
los jóvenes o reformar el sistema de
pensiones para dar más peso a la parte
privada pues bien la falta de respuesta
a negociación y liderazgo del presidente
duque terminó congelando cualquier
programa de cambio
[Música]
en 2020 las protestas volvieron contra
la brutalidad policial y luego en 2021
el gobierno de duke presentó sin mucha
pedagogía ni mucho consenso una reforma
fiscal para elevar el impuesto sobre la
renta a las clases medias y el iba sobre
los bienes básicos y poder así reducir
los impuestos sobre la actividad
productiva la reforma podía tener
sentido pero las cosas se hicieron tan
mal que volvió a incendiar las calles
y al final el propio duque pues terminó
haciendo básicamente lo contrario
aprobar otra reforma fiscal que
básicamente subía los impuestos a las
empresas del 31 al 35 por ciento
exactamente lo contrario de lo que
defendió durante años así que al final
cambios en el modelo económico pues más
bien ninguno luego otro terreno
resbaladizo fue la violencia y la
seguridad otra de las grandes promesas
de duke donde las cosas pues tampoco le
pudieron salir peor evidentemente de
colombiano ha regresado a los niveles de
violencia de finales de los 90 y de
principios del nuevo siglo pero las
cosas no han ido nada pero que nada bien
el país está en una situación
absolutamente dramática debido a los
problemas de seguridad que existen tanto
lo que tiene que ver con el conflicto
armado como en lo que tiene que ver con
la seguridad en las ciudades camilo
[ __ ] profesor asociado del
departamento de relaciones
internacionales de la pontificia
universidad javeriana de bogotá durante
el mandato de bando que la violencia se
ha recrudecido por la creciente
actividad de las bandas de narcotráfico
o los disidentes de las farc y ln para
que os hagáis una idea tan sólo entre
2019 y 2022 ochocientos treinta y cinco
líderes sociales y vecinales fueron
asesinados por todo el país al tiempo
las acciones de combate de grupos
armados también se volvieron a disparar
fijaos
y si a todo ello le sumamos los efectos
de la pandemia pues nos podemos hacer
una idea de por qué duque ha terminado
con un nivel de aprobación está bajo
claro que no todo es culpa suya ni mucho
menos amigos amigas que los colombianos
se han dado un golpe en la mesa tiene
también mucho que ver con esto atentos
[Música]
sueños rotos
queridos amigos amigas el puñetazo en la
mesa que esta vez han pegado los
colombianos no ha tenido que ver con la
típica crisis a la que este país nos
tiene acostumbrados no ha tenido que ver
con las guerrillas el crimen organizado
los narcóticos o la pobreza en el mundo
rural no en este caso el descontento
procede sobre todo de los jóvenes y de
las zonas urbanas que sienten una enorme
frustración por los sueños rotos sí vale
por supuesto la pandemia ha jugado un
papel clave en este sentimiento porque
si la economía colombiana se ha
recuperado y su producción es hoy mayor
que antes de la pandemia girón no ha
ocurrido lo mismo con el empleo que
sigue por debajo
con las tasas de pobreza para que os
hagáis una idea en 2021 casi el 40 por
ciento de los colombianos vivían sumidos
en la pobreza y más del 12% en la
extrema pobreza y claro si tenemos en
cuenta que colombia tiene más de 50
millones de habitantes hablamos de
muchos millones de personas en una
situación desesperada
[Música]
por ejemplo en términos reales cerca de
20 millones de colombianos sobreviven
con menos de 89 dólares al mes una
enorme cantidad de personas que además
están experimentando un daño gigantesco
por culpa de la inflación porque por
culpa de la energía y la crisis
alimentaria internacional los precios
están subiendo más rápido que en ningún
otro momento de los últimos 20 años para
colmo colombia es atrás perú el país con
más incidencia del trabajo informal algo
más de 6 de cada 10 trabajadores no
tiene un empleo formal con todo lo que
ello conlleva así que todo esto ha sido
por así decirlo la gota que ha colmado
el vaso y que erosionado las esperanzas
de cientos de miles millones de jóvenes
pero un momento amigos amigas porque
sobre todo la enorme frustración que
vive el país tiene que ver con este
gráfico cree está su atención porque
esta es una de las grandes claves del
cambio electoral
[Música]
durante las últimas décadas colombia ha
hecho muchos avances pero el ascensor
social simplemente no funciona ni en el
campo donde el 80% de las tierras
agrícolas siguen en manos del 1% de los
propietarios ni tampoco en gran medida
en las ciudades en colombia si naces
pobre lo más probable es que seas pobre
y que lo sean también tus hijos tus
nietos y hasta tus tártara nietos y está
acreditado que la falta de evolución es
uno de los mayores combustibles para el
enfado y el descontento social por así
decirlo durante los últimos años y el
globo de un supuesto sueño colombiano ha
saltado por los aires es el sueño roto
que ha llevado a los colombianos a decir
basta porque cuando sientes que no
tienes nada que perder el voto por la
revolución el cambio drástico o
simplemente contra la élite pues se
vuelve una opción mucho más razonable
pero dicho esto la pregunta es y ahora
que pues atentos
la nueva colombia
más
petro se las veía muy felices conocido
como aureliano y andrés durante su paso
por el m-19 este antiguo guerrillero
reconvertido ahora en economista sigue
siendo muy pero que muy de izquierdas y
con todos los problemas de colombia vio
su gran oportunidad fue uno de los
grandes impulsores de las protestas que
inundaron las calles colombianas durante
los últimos años y por supuesto se
presentó a las elecciones con promesas
de todo tipo educación superior gratuita
empleos públicos garantizados para los
desempleados más gastos social pensiones
más altas etcétera etcétera y todo ello
al tiempo que promete poner fin a las
nuevas exploraciones de petróleo y gas y
también a aprobar una enorme reforma
fiscal para que toda la factura la
paguen sólo las rentas más altas
especialmente en las 4.000 personas más
adineradas de colombia y cuál es el
problema pues básicamente que las
cuentas no cuadran según petro su
reforma fiscal recauda entre 50 y 65
billones de pesos pues bien se estima
que tan solo sus principales promesas
cuestan más del doble
así que qué queréis que os diga todo
apunta que estamos ante el típico
programa que consiste en un cheque
blanco para ganar votos pero que luego
el cheque a la hora de la verdad no
tiene fondos y si a todo ello le sumamos
que petro también quiere distanciarse de
washington subir aranceles y renegociar
los acuerdos de libre comercio aunque
éstos hayan disparado las exportaciones
colombianas no es extraño que el propio
banco de la república haya empezado a
detectar algunas fugas de capitales
antes de las elecciones sin embargo un
momento porque a petro le surgió de
repente un problema
ahora se tiene que enfrentar a un
candidato que es mucho más a usaid er
que él y que tras la primera vuelta
puede haberse convertido en el gran
favorito hablamos de rodolfo hernández
un empresario que se ha presentado como
independiente y que ha concentrado sus
mensajes contra la casta política el ex
alcalde de bucaramanga al que algunos
conocen como el tram colombiano parece
defender el libre comercio y la
propiedad al mismo tiempo que también
habla de acabar con las injusticias
sociales y sobre todo con los
privilegios de los políticos por ejemplo
ha prometido renunciar al sueldo del
presidente acabar con la mayoría de los
coches oficiales reducir el número de
asesores o bajar el sueldo a los
congresistas también defiende mantener
el gasto público bajo control buscar la
forma de recortar el iba casi un 50 por
ciento y sustituir todos los subsidios
por una especie de ingreso mínimo pues
bien el caso es que ahora su candidatura
aparece lista para recoger los votos de
la mayoría de candidatos que no pasaron
a la segunda vuelta el propio federico
gutiérrez y ccoo ya le ha dado su apoyo
y todo apunta a que otros candidatos
como fajardo o yo milton y enrique gómez
también se identifican más con él a
pesar de que ideológicamente es un
candidato incógnita
[Música]
así que quién sabe pero está claro que
si los colombianos quieren dar un golpe
en la mesa contra la casta política sin
tener que recurrir a un programa muy
pero que muy de izquierdas este puede
ser su candidato y sabéis que esas al
menos la esperanza del propio rodolfo
hernández un candidato que los analistas
económicos dicen que tranquilizaría
mucho a los mercados pero sea como sea
lo que está claro es que ni uno ni otro
candidato controlan el parlamento aunque
desde luego petro puede tenerlo mucho
más difícil para lograr consensos metro
podría decir que sus políticas son a b y
c pero eso no significa que pueda
cumplir con ellas en el peor de los
casos petro presidía un gobierno
altamente conflictivo que no haría nada
en lugar de un gobierno que desmantela
las instituciones de colombia luis
fernando mejía director del grupo de
reflexión económico fedesarrollo amigos
colombia tiene un sistema
presidencialista y las elecciones
legislativas tuvieron lugar el 13 de
marzo del 2022 la alianza de petro logró
el mejor resultado pero se quedó muy
lejos de cualquier mayoría tanto en la
cámara de representantes como en el
senado donde apenas tiene el 15 y el 18
por ciento de los escaños
respectivamente
así que sea cual sea finalmente el
resultado todo apunta que podemos
esperar cierta estabilidad tal y como
por ejemplo ocurrido en méxico dónde al
final habló pues ha tenido en gran
medida las manos atadas lo que está
claro es que colombia necesita poner en
marcha ese ascensor social que hoy está
parado y que está condenando a millones
y millones de colombianos esa tiene que
ser la gran prioridad pero dicho esto
turno para ti qué impresión está
generado el resultado electoral te
parece lógico que los colombianos hayan
dado un golpe en la mesa que el
candidato te gusta más petro o rodolfo
hernández y si nos estás viendo desde
colombia que por cierto sois muchísimos
por quién vais a votar pues dejándonos
por aquí abajo estos comentarios y ahora
si este vídeo se ha resultado
interesante no olvidéis darle a like y
suscribiros abisal político una vez más
muchas gracias por estar ahí un saludo y
hasta la próxima
[Música]